C was never a particularly elegant language. That's just. Pascal, by comparison, is a very elegant language. C was always difficult to parse compared to Pascal. So there were a lot of things working against it. But one of the things working for it is C from the get-go tended to have direct compilers targeting the assembly language of whatever machine you were working on. Where Pascal still, for the most part, relied on P code with a few exceptions. Apple had a compiler to 68K, but almost everybody else was running through P code.
C 从来都不是一种特别优雅的语言。情况就是这样。相比之下，Pascal 是一种非常优雅的语言。与 Pascal 相比，C 语言一直很难解析。因此，有许多因素对它不利。但对它有利的一点是，C 语言从一开始就倾向于直接针对你正在使用的任何机器的汇编语言生成直接编译器。而 Pascal 在大多数情况下仍然依赖 P 代码，只有少数例外。Apple 拥有一个针对 68K 的编译器，但几乎其他所有人都在通过 P 代码运行。
And so Pascal was viewed as being slow and interpreted. And the whole object Pascal thing was viewed as being Apple's extension. And so it did not get wide use outside of the Apple ecosystem. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 162, recorded on December 12th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue our conversation with Sean Parent. And in this episode, chat with him about the history of Pascal, Pascal versus C, other Nicholas Wirth programming languages, and more. We've now skipped ahead over Zach. Happy holidays.
因此，Pascal 被视为慢速且解释执行的。整个对象 Pascal 被视为 Apple 的扩展。因此它在 Apple 生态系统之外没有得到广泛使用。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 162 期，录制于 2023 年 12 月 12 日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人布莱斯将继续我们与肖恩·帕伦特的对话。在本期节目中，我们将与他聊聊 Pascal 的历史、Pascal 与 C 的对比、尼克劳斯·维尔特的其它编程语言等内容。我们现在已经跳过了扎克。节日快乐。
You know, the holidays have passed, and I think it should be right before New Year's... What do you call that with respect to the... What are we, Julian? Gregorian calendar? One of the two. Happy New Year's or Happy New Year's Eve if you're listening to this now. And the original reason that we were bringing Sean back is...
你知道，假期已经过去了，我觉得应该就在新年前……你对那个怎么称呼……我们现在是朱利安历？格里高利历？两者之一。如果你现在正在收听，祝你新年快乐或除夕快乐。我们请肖恩回来的最初原因是……
We will link this at the top of the show notes to this episode. We did a series of conversations with Jonathan O'Connor where we were talking about a plethora of stuff, but a couple of the episodes focused on Pascal versus Ada versus C. And there was a bunch of stuff that we chatted about, but Sean, you ended up replying to, I believe it was the tweet on episode 154, which was I think like part two or part three of that talk. And I'm not going to read out everything because it was about three or four tweets in a row. But you mentioned a bunch of stuff that didn't get mentioned in that conversation. You know, if I peruse through this tweet, it's mentioning the Apple Lisa and Mac OS were written in a combination of Pascal and 68K. And then you mentioned a bunch of different books, a bunch of different computers. And I'll probably just leave it there
我们会在本期节目的节目说明顶部链接这个内容。我们与乔纳森·奥康纳进行了一系列对话，讨论了大量的事情，但其中几集重点探讨了 Pascal 与 Ada 与 C 的对比。我们聊了很多事情，但肖恩，你最终回复了，我相信那是针对第 154 集的推文，那大概是那次谈话的第二部分或第三部分。我不会把所有内容都读出来，因为那是连续的三四条推文。但你提到了很多在那次对话中没有被提及的事情。你知道，如果我浏览这条推文，它提到了 Apple Lisa 和 Mac OS 是用 Pascal 和 68K 的组合编写的。然后你提到了许多不同的书籍、许多不同的计算机，我大概就说这么多
and just throw it over to you. And you can start wherever you want to start with the things that we missed and that you were sort of screaming in your head, how come they're not mentioning this? How come they're not mentioning this? And that's what the next, either part two or part three,
然后把话题抛给你。你可以从你想要开始的任何地方开始，谈谈我们遗漏的事情，以及你当时在脑海里大喊“他们怎么不提这个？他们怎么不提这个？”的事情。这就是接下来的第二部分或第三部分，
or maybe do we one part of this conversation will be. Yeah, so a combination of that. And then then I was listening to software unscripted and and you made a guest appearance there, Connor, on on that podcast. And you mentioned that you were born, I think, in 1990, if that's correct. That is correct. That is correct, yes. Yeah, which just made me feel very old. I joined Apple three years before you were born. I mean, we were interviewing on my other podcast at Raycast, Brian Ellingsgaard, who is 18, which means that he was born in 2005. So, you know, I don't, I didn't know.
或者也许我们将这次对话分为一部分。是的，这是这些内容的结合。然后，然后我在听 Software Unscripted，康纳，你在那个播客上作为嘉宾出现过。你提到你出生于 1990 年左右，如果我没记错的话。没错，确实如此。是的。是的，这让我觉得自己老了。我加入 Apple 时，你还没出生呢。我的意思是，我们在我的另一个播客 Raycast 上采访了 18 岁的布莱恩·埃林斯加德，这意味着他出生于 2005 年。所以，你知道，我不知道，我不知道。
People shouldn't be that young. I know. So like, I didn't know how young he was. And then when he said he was 18, I was like, oh God, that makes sense. If you're feeling old about me and I'm feeling old about Bryant, you know, it's just this vicious, vicious feedback loop here. Yeah. Yeah.
人们不应该那么年轻。我知道。所以，我不知道他有多年轻。然后当他说他 18 岁时，我就想，哦天哪，这说得通。如果你因为我而觉得自己老，而我又因为布莱恩而觉得自己老，你知道，这只是一个恶性循环。是的。是的。
And like, like not, not knowing kind of you know pascal and and that history was was interesting pascal had had a had a a pretty significant heyday and even going all the way back to the apple 2 uh there was a an implementation of ucsd pascal which if you wanted to you know program you know a you know, a 68K processor, which was the old Apple II, was an 8-bit processor. So even doing, you know, 16-bit assembly language that executed in 6502 as a way to write 16-bit assembly language easier. So Pascal had a bit of a heyday at that time, and there was an implementation from University of California, San Diego, UCSD. That's what I was thinking that UCSD stood for,
而且，就像不知道 Pascal 和那段历史一样，这很有趣，Pascal 曾经有过一段非常辉煌的时期，甚至一直追溯到 Apple II，当时有 UCSD Pascal 的实现，如果你想编写 68K 处理器程序（旧的 Apple II 是一个 8 位处理器），UCSD Pascal 就是一个选择。因此，甚至执行 16 位汇编语言作为在 6502 上运行以更轻松地编写 16 位汇编语言的方法。所以 Pascal 在当时有一段辉煌时期，加州大学圣迭戈分校（UCSD）有一个实现。这就是我当时想到的 UCSD 代表的意思，
but I was like, that can't be, there must be some other acronym and that's the only one I know, so that's what I'm thinking of. But that's just what it stood for. Yeah, so an implementation came out of there and it was based off of something called p-code where p-code is basically a bytecode
但我想，这不可能，一定还有别的缩写，而那是我唯一知道的一个，所以我想到的就是那个。但它确实就代表这个。是的，一个实现就是从那里诞生的，它基于一种叫做 P 代码的东西，P 代码基本上是一种字节码，
that's easily interpreted. And so the idea with UCSD Pascal was you could, it was kind of pre-Java, Java, it was you could compile your Pascal code down to p-code, and then you could run that p-code any place that had a p-code interpreter, and building a p- code interpreter was dead simple so it meant that you could write write pascal code and have it run basically anywhere so pascal itself became kind of the moral equivalent to what we would now think of as as python which is kind
很容易被解释。因此，UCSD Pascal 的想法是，它有点像是 Java 之前的 Java，你可以将 Pascal 代码编译成 P 代码，然后你可以在任何拥有 P 代码解释器的 地方运行该 P 代码，并且构建一个 P 代码解释器极其简单，这意味着你可以编写 Pascal 代码并使其基本上在任何地方运行。因此，Pascal 本身在某种程度上成为了我们现在认为是 Python 的精神等价物，后者有点
of an application language if you needed to to write software and you weren't, you know, to solve a problem, right, using a programming language as an app, right, so you're writing software to solve a problem as opposed to building a product. Pascal got an awful lot of use in that environment. And it also became a great teaching language and then it started to bleed into system languages so the the original uh lisa uh was written the operating system itself was written in a combination of pascal uh compiled to 68 000 and 68k assembly language and then then Larry Tesler, who had come out of Xerox PARC, worked with Nicholas Wirth, who created Pascal to define Object Pascal. And that kind of became the language of choice
像是一种应用语言，如果你需要编写软件而不是……去解决问题，对吧，使用编程语言作为应用程序，对吧，所以你编写软件是为了解决问题，而不是为了构建产品。Pascal 在这种环境中得到了非常广泛的使用。它也成为了一种绝佳的教学语言，然后开始渗透到系统语言中。因此最初的 Lisa 操作系统本身是用 Pascal（编译为 68000）和 68K 汇编语言的组合编写的，然后曾供职于施乐帕克研究中心的拉里·特斯勒与创建了 Pascal 的尼克劳斯·维尔特合作，定义了对象 Pascal。这在某种程度上成为了在 Lisa 上编写应用程序的首选语言，
for writing applications on the Lisa. And that same basic model moved into the early macintosh so the initial macintosh the operating system was written in a combination of 68k assembly language and pascal and then most applications written on top of the early macintoshes were written in object pascal you know object pascal eventually morphed into Delphi. So there's a direct lineage there. But what happened was Unix took root in universities and kind of displaced many computer operating systems like VaxVMS got eventually displaced with Unix distributions. And Unix was very much built around the C language. And so C started getting taught in universities and displaced Pascal as a language of choice for a teaching language.
而同样的基本模型延续到了早期的 Macintosh 中。因此，最初的 Macintosh 操作系统是用 68K 汇编语言和 Pascal 的组合编写的，然后在早期 Macintosh 上编写的大多数应用程序都是用对象 Pascal 编写的。对象 Pascal 最终演变成了 Delphi。所以这里有着直接的传承。但发生的事情是，Unix 在大学里扎根，并取代了许多计算机操作系统，例如 VaxVMS 最终被 Unix 发行版所取代。而 Unix 很大程度上是围绕 C 语言构建的。因此，C 语言开始在大学里教授，并取代 Pascal 成为首选的教学语言。
And there became this large ecosystem of developer tooling built in C. And so there became all these external pressures to move towards C. So eventually in kind of early 90s timeframe, Apple transitioned Mac development from Pascal to C. And Photoshop was originally written in, in object Pascal in 1990. And let's see, probably around 92, I would guess Photoshop was ported from object Pascal to C plus plus. And that was back in C front days where it was,
并且出现了一个用 C 语言构建的庞大开发工具生态系统。因此，所有这些外部压力都促使人们转向 C 语言。最终在 90 年代初期的某个时间点，Apple 将 Mac 的开发从 Pascal 过渡到了 C 语言。Photoshop 最初是用 1990 年的对象 Pascal 编写的。让我想想，大概在 92 年左右，我猜 Photoshop 从对象 Pascal 移植到了 C++。那是 Cfront 时代，
you know, Bjarne's compiler that compiled C plus plus code into C. And then you compile a C code into your machine code. And wait, so you said that this shift was just happening because Unix was gaining popularity and Unix was associated with C. And you mentioned that C started to get taught in universities because of this.
你知道，那是比雅尼的编译器，它将 C++ 代码编译成 C 代码。然后你将 C 代码编译成你的机器码。等等，所以你说这种转变的发生只是因为 Unix 越来越受欢迎，而 Unix 与 C 语言相关。你提到 C 语言因此开始在大学里教授。
But at the same time, Pascal and Object Pascal or versions of Pascal were also being taught. So it was just momentum that Unix and c had more momentum than the the family of pascal languages yeah it was it was largely just momentum it got to the point where you know it was like well i could write this in pascal but look there's all these these tools that do this in c and you start hiring people and it became hard to hire somebody who knew Pascal. They knew C. So there was this momentum shift.
但与此同时，Pascal 和对象 Pascal 或 Pascal 的版本也正在被教授。所以这只是势头的问题，Unix 和 C 语言比 Pascal 语言家族拥有更大的势头。是的，这在很大程度上只是势头问题。发展到一定程度，你知道，就像“我可以用 Pascal 来写这个，但你看，有所有这些用 C 语言做这件事的工具。”当你开始招聘人员时，招聘一个懂 Pascal 的人变得很困难。他们都懂 C。所以存在这种势头转变。
And from kind of building an operating system, there were certain things that were a little bit easier to express in C. It was just easier to circumvent the type system and kind of do whatever you wanted. Although in Pascal, Apple would do that by just dropping into 68k assembly language and writing little snippets like that where C was not sufficient. But, you know, for a while there, it was very unclear that
从构建操作系统的角度来看，有些事情在 C 语言中表达起来稍微容易一些。绕过类型系统并随心所欲地做你想做的事只是更容易一些。尽管在 Pascal 中，Apple 会通过直接转入 68K 汇编语言并编写像这样的小代码片段来做到这一点，在 C 语言不够用的情况下。但是，你知道，在那段时间里，很不确定的是
C was never a particularly elegant language. Pascal, by comparison, is a very elegant language. C was always difficult to parse compared to Pascal. So there were a lot of things working against it. But one of the things working for it is C from the get-go tended to have direct compilers targeting the assembly language of whatever machine you were working on, where Pascal still, for the most part, relied on p-code with a few exceptions. Apple had a compiler to 68K, but almost everybody else was running through p-code, and so Pascal was viewed as being slow and interpreted. The whole object Pascal thing was viewed as being Apple's extension, and so it did not get wide use outside of the Apple ecosystem. Talking about p-code reminds me that, and this is going to be embarrassing for Connor and I, during our previous discussion, Connor, I don't
C 从来都不是一项特别优雅的语言。相比之下，Pascal 是非常优雅的语言。与 Pascal 相比，C 语言一直很难解析。因此，有许多因素对它不利。但对它有利的一点是，C 语言从一开始就倾向于直接针对你正在使用的任何机器的汇编语言生成直接编译器，而 Pascal 在大多数情况下仍然依赖 p 代码，只有少数例外。Apple 拥有一个针对 68K 的编译器，但几乎其他所有人都在通过 p 代码运行，因此 Pascal 被视为缓慢且解释执行的。整个对象 Pascal 被视为 Apple 的扩展，因此它在 Apple 生态系统之外没有得到广泛使用。谈到 p 代码让我想起，这对于康纳和我来说将是尴尬的，在我们之前的讨论中，康纳，我不
think we talked about the fact that I'm pretty certain that the book ADSP, Algorithms Plus Data Structures Equals Programs, is largely in Pascal. And in fact, I believe that my original encounter with P-code was that there's a like a simple day, they write like a little Pascal compiler in the book, with a very slimmed down version of the VM. And I only just now remember, so clearly neither of us have read the book that recently. Well, I mean, because of the conversation with Jonathan, I did go out immediately after recording that. I bought a hard copy book and it's sitting on my shelf now. And because it was when he said that, yes, it's considered like a teaching book for Pascal. I was like, oh, that's, you know, clearly we haven't read it.
认为我们讨论过这样一个事实，我非常确定书名 ADSP（Algorithms Plus Data Structures Equals Programs，算法+数据结构=程序）很大程度上是用 Pascal 编写的。事实上，我相信我最初接触 p 代码是因为书中有一个简单的日子，他们用书中编写了一个简陋的 Pascal 编译器，配合一个非常精简的虚拟机版本。我直到现在才想起来，所以显然我们俩最近都没有读过这本书。嗯，我的意思是，因为与乔纳森的对话，我在录制完之后确实立刻出门了。我买了一本纸质书，现在它正放在我的书架上。因为当他说到这一点时，是的，它被认为是一本针对 Pascal 的教学书，我就想，哦，你知道，显然我们没有读过它。
But like we didn't even know the basics of what I thought this book was like, a generic just kind of data structures and algorithms book. But yes, so at some point we will read it. I did not know that about in the ADSP book. Yeah, there was Turbo Pascal first appeared on, well, I was going to say Windows, but DOS, I think would be correct. So on Microsoft's platform. And yeah, Turbo Pascal was just an amazing, you know, little IDE and compiler that was just blazing fast. And it was the same name as the Pascal that Apple had on Apple II. But Apple Pascal on a Mac was an interpreted Pascal that was very much centered around kind of, you know, programming as an application, right, as opposed to programming an application. So same way you would use Python today, right?
但我们甚至不知道这本书的基本情况，我以前以为它是一本通用的数据结构和算法书。但是是的，所以在某个时候我们会读它。我不知道 ADSP 书里有这回事。是的，Turbo Pascal 最初出现在——嗯，我本来想说是 Windows，但 DOS 应该更准确。所以在微软的平台上。是的，Turbo Pascal 只是一个令人惊叹的小型 IDE 和编译器，速度惊人。它和 Apple 在 Apple II 上拥有的 Pascal 同名。但 Mac 上的 Apple Pascal 是一种解释型 Pascal，非常集中于……你知道的，作为应用程序进行编程，对吧，而不是编程一个应用程序。所以其方式和你今天使用 Python 的方式一样，对吧？
You just want to solve a problem. And it was, you know, very slick environment and debugging environment, very easy to use, very limited. I think in your talk, somebody said, like, you could only have one file for a Pascal program. Not true, but that was true in Apple Pascal. And that file itself could only be 32K in size. And I actually wrote a school project in Pascal and ended up writing another tool in Compile Pascal that would process my Pascal to minify it so that, because I had to turn in the school project in Apple Pascal, and so that I could fit more in the 32K. And so I turned in two listings. One was the unminified code,
你只是想解决一个问题。而且，你知道，这是一个非常流畅的环境和调试环境，非常易于使用，也非常有限。我想在你的演讲中，有人说，例如，一个 Pascal 程序只能有一个文件。这不真实，但在 Apple Pascal 中是真的。而且该文件本身的大小只能是 32K。我实际上用 Pascal 编写了一个学校项目，最后用 Compiled Pascal 编写了另一个工具来处理我的 Pascal 以对其进行精简，因为我必须在 Apple Pascal 中交学校项目，以便我能将更多内容塞进 32K 中。所以我交了两份清单。一份是未精简的代码，
and then one was the code that actually ran, which was greatly reduced. And probably a lot less readable. And a lot less readable. Also included, there was an escape patch so you could execute assembly language and so there were sections of code where i just hand wrote them in assembly language and escaped from pascal to assembly language so so not completely legit but you know it was it was interesting i think a lot of ideas from Apple Pascal then got carried over into, and Turbo Pascal, into ThinkC and then into MetroWorks Code Warrior. I think the other thing that damaged Pascal
另一份是实际运行的代码，该代码被极大地精简了。而且可能可读性差得多。可读性差得多。其中还包含了一个转义补丁，因此你可以执行汇编语言，所以有些代码段我是用汇编语言手写的，并从 Pascal 转义到汇编语言，所以不是完全合法的，但你知道，这很有趣，我认为 Apple Pascal 和 Turbo Pascal 中的许多想法后来被带到了 ThinkC，然后带到了 MetroWerks CodeWarrior。我认为损害 Pascal 的另一件事是
was Nicholas Wirth didn't, you know, he did Pascal and then he did Object Pascal, and then from what he learned from Object Pascal, he created Modula 2. Well, first Modula and then Modula 2. And then created Oberon. And so, you know, he was a university guy. And so he was kind of creating this stream of little languages. And so abandoning his previous work. And so I think that ended up damaging things right there got to be the point where you know i i did work actually shipped a product that
尼克劳斯·维尔特没有，你知道，他做了 Pascal，然后做了对象 Pascal，然后从对象 Pascal 中学到的东西，他创建了 Modula 2。嗯，先是 Modula，然后是 Modula 2。然后创建了 Oberon。所以，你知道，他是一个大学里的人。所以他有点在创造这种小语言流。从而放弃了他以前的工作。所以我认为这最终损害了事情，发展到一定程度，你知道，我确实做过，实际上发布过一个产品，
was partially written in module 2 before metro works did code warrior greg galanos wrote a module 2 compiler for mac I probably still have someplace here my Modula 2 book. People were doing, well, is it going to be Modula 2 next? Are we doing Modula 2? Are we doing Object Pascal? Oh, wait, now we're doing Oberon?
在 MetroWerks 推出 CodeWarrior 之前，它部分是用 Modula 2 编写的，格雷格·加拉诺斯为 Mac 编写了一个 Modula 2 编译器。我可能在这里的某个地方还有我的 Modula 2 书。人们在想，嗯，接下来会是 Modula 2 吗？我们要用 Modula 2 吗？我们要用对象 Pascal 吗？哦，等等，现在我们要用 Oberon 吗？
What's going on? And so just that lineage kind of confused the marketplace. And C++ had this much more straightforward story that is uh it's incredibly reminiscent of what i mean i've told this story a couple times on the podcast of what arthur whitney has done with the all the different k languages that he's written that he'll finish with one even more aggressively will delete it, clear all of the remnants of it off his workstation or laptop
到底怎么回事？因此，这种传承有点让市场感到困惑。而 C++ 有一个更直接的故事，它非常让人想起——我的意思是，我在播客中讲过几次这个故事——亚瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney）用他编写的所有不同的 K 语言所做的事情，他会用一种语言完成，甚至更激进地删除它，清除他工作站或笔记本电脑上它的所有残余，
and then move on to the next thing. And yeah, there's definitely that same kind of effect on the community that's using it. You know, people, is K6 going to be the final one? Is K7, is there going to be another one? And I think every time that a new one is created, people are more and more cautious to move to the next one or do we just keep using what we have? Yeah yeah and i wonder because the next name that comes to
然后转向下一件事。是的，对使用它的社区肯定有同样的影响。你知道，人们会问，K6 会是最后一个吗？K7 会是吗，还会有另一个吗？我认为每次创建一个新的，人们就会越来越谨慎地转向下一个，或者我们只是继续使用我们手头的东西？是的，是的，我想知道，因为下一个浮现在脑海的名字
mind is on our andrew hausberg out of microsoft but he's almost the opposite of that has worked on a ton of different like majorly successful languages but has not it hasn't been like you know they he made sure that the community was going to survive and continue to thrive and then just moved on to the next project, which I guess is for any aspiring programming language creators, all, in which case there'll be a bit of excitement around that. But I had no idea that that was kind of the reputation around what Virth was doing. Yeah, I've often thought if you take a compiler class in school, you basically learn the Dragon Book, which is a great book. But unless you're going to end up building compilers out of school, which very few people will, I think it's overkill. And Nicholas Wirth's languages and his compiler books are much simpler. The way Nicholas Wirth always built a language, I call it
是微软的安德烈·哈斯伯格（Anders Hejlsberg），但他几乎与此相反，他曾参与过大量不同的、取得巨大成功的语言的工作，但并没有像——你知道的，他们确保社区能够生存并继续繁荣，然后才转向下一个项目，我想对于任何有志于创建编程语言的人来说，所有这些都会围绕它产生一些兴奋感。但我完全不知道围绕维尔特的做法有这样的声誉。是的，我经常想，如果你在学校上过编译器课，你基本上学习的是《龙书》，这是一本好书。但除非你毕业后最终要构建编译器，而极少数人会这样做，否则我认为这是大材小用。尼克劳斯·维尔特的语言和他的编译器书籍要简单得多。尼克劳斯·维尔特构建语言的方式，我称之为
LL1 to the bottom, which is he would define an LL1 grammar, which is a very simple recursive descent grammar with no backtracking. If you don't get success on the next token, then your code is wrong. And his compilers all generated code straight from the parser. He never built an AST. So he would compile straight from the parser into P code or into assembly language. And so it's a much simpler approach if you want to build a quick compiler one-off. It's really easy to build a little stack machine interpreter and then build a compiler that's recursive descent, and you just generate the code for your own stack machine straight out of your parser, and you don't deal with ASTs, and you don't deal with extra complexity.
自底向上的 LL1，也就是他会定义一个 LL1 文法，这是一个非常简单的递归下降文法，没有回溯。如果在下一个标记上没有成功，那么你的代码就是错的。他的编译器都是直接从解析器生成代码的。他从未构建过抽象语法树（AST）。因此他会直接从解析器编译成 P 代码或汇编语言。因此，如果你想快速构建一个一次性的编译器，这是一种简单得多的方法。构建一个小型栈式机器解释器，然后构建一个递归下降的编译器真的很容易，你只需直接从解析器中为你的栈式机器生成代码，而不用处理 AST，也不用处理额外的复杂性。
But is a Lisp really like its scheme in the Dragonbook, right? I believe it is scheme in the Dragonbook, right? I believe it is Scheme in the Dragonbook. Yeah. Is it really that much harder? I mean, I do think they build an AST in that book, but is it really that much harder to parse? Oh, no. It's not that the parser in that language is that much simpler.
但 Lisp 真的像《龙书》中的 Scheme 那样吗？我相信《龙书》里的是 Scheme，对吧？我相信《龙书》里的是 Scheme。是的。真的有那么难吗？我的意思是，我认为他们在那本书里构建了一个 AST，但解析真的有那么难吗？哦，不。并不是说那种语言中的解析器简单得多。
It's just that they go through all the steps of building a compiler, and it's like you build your AST, and then you do passes on it for optimizers. And you look, the Dragonbook is a thick book and nobody makes it through the Dragonbook in a quarter. I mean, come on, you're not actually doing that. I can't remember the name for Virat's book, but it's a small, small book. And if you look like you know nicholas veert built i think i mentioned it on twitter um a machine called the lilith which was basically a modula 2 machine what do you mean by he built a machine i mean they were manufacturing and you could order a lilith and you know like you could order an apple 2 you could order a lilith it was an expensive machine and did he design the chip
只是他们经历了构建编译器的所有步骤，就像你构建你的 AST，然后对其进行优化器通道处理。你看，《龙书》是一本厚书，没有人能在在一个学期内看完《龙书》。我的意思是，拜托，你实际上并没有在做这件事。我不记得维尔特那本书的名字了，但它是一本很小很小的书。如果你看看——你知道尼克劳斯·维尔特构建的，我想我在推特上提到过，一台名为 Lilith 的机器，它基本上是一台 Modula 2 机器。你说的他构建了一台机器是什么意思？我的意思是他们在制造，你可以订购一台 Lilith，你知道就像你可以订购一台 Apple II 一样，你可以订购一台 Lilith，那是一台昂贵的机器，他设计了芯片
or he just built it? It was a combination of doing the chip design because the processor on it basically executed the bytecode coming out of the Module 2 compiler directly. And so it had its own custom CPU, its own custom hardware. It had a portrait display. It had its own module tube-based operating system, kind of a window-based operating system.
还是只是构建了它？这是芯片设计的结合，因为其上的处理器基本上直接执行来自 Modula 2 编译器的字节码。因此它有自己的定制 CPU，自己的定制硬件。它有一个纵向显示器。它有自己的基于 Modula 2 的操作系统，一种基于窗口的操作系统。
Quite an impressive feat at the time. You can look up, you can probably find emulators someplace to run a Lilith. At the time, I salivated over these things. It was like, oh, I really want a Lilith computer, but no possible way that I could afford one. You basically need to be in research at a university with some kind of government funding to get a Lilith. It was one of those dead ends in the evolution of
在当时是一个相当了不起的壮举。你可以查阅，你可能能在某个地方找到模拟器来运行 Lilith。在当时，我对这些东西垂涎三尺。就像，哦，我真的很想要一台 Lilith 计算机，但绝对没有办法买得起。你基本上需要在大学里从事研究工作并获得某种政府资助才能拥有一台 Lilith。那是硬件和软件演进中的死胡同之一。
hardware and software. It's an interesting era because these days you could not, I think, create your own machine at the same scale. You need to be... A lot of people kind of do now with FPGAs. So I kind of think you could these days. You could basically build your own processor FPGAs and build, you know, I kind of think you could these days with, you could basically build your own processor FPGAs and build custom ASICs. The only place where I see people doing that is kind of emulating old game hardware. But you don't think that that era in the past was a golden era
这是一个有趣的时代，因为如今我认为你无法以相同的规模创建你自己的机器。你需要……很多人现在用 FPGA 做到了这一点。所以我有点认为你现在可以了。你基本上可以构建你自己的处理器 FPGA 并构建——我有点认为你现在可以了，你可以基本上构建你自己的处理器 FPGA 并构建定制 ASIC。我看到人们这样做的唯一地方是在模拟旧的游戏硬件。但你不认为过去的那个时代是硬件和软件设计的黄金时代，
of hardware and software design and that we're now in a much more homogenized era and an era where the, certainly the high end of chips is only for, or only the high end, or let me put it another way, the high end of computers today. And I don't mean like the most powerful computers, but like, you know,
而我们现在处于一个更加同质化的时代，一个……当然，芯片的高端仅用于……或者说高端，或者让我换个方式说，当今计算机的高端产品。我不是指功能最强大的计算机，而是指……
the best computers, you know, the, the, the computers in your phone that are in your laptop, you know, something like the Nintendo Switch, those are produced by gigantic corporations and have huge, huge amounts of investment to go into them to produce them. Whereas, you know, back in the 70s and the 80s, you could create a thing that was a good thing at a much smaller
最好的计算机，你知道的，你手机里的计算机，你笔记本电脑里的计算机，比如任天堂 Switch，那些是由巨大公司生产的，并投入了巨大、巨额的投资来生产它们。然而，早在 70 年代和 80 年代，你可以以小得多的规模创造出一个好东西
scale. Not quite maybe in your garage, but sort of close. It's interesting that, you know, I don't think, well, it's somewhat the same. It's like, you know, Steve and Steve, right, created the Apple One, you know, famously in the garage. And, you know, did the work for the Apple Two as well. Very small scale. And there's no way that you would do that today and compete with with a Mac or a Windows box. There's just no way. But at the same time for them they were creating something that ultimately would compete with you know minis and mainframes and there was no way for them to directly compete with that yeah and surprisingly the barrier to do like small entry-level hardware
规模。也许不完全在你的车库里，但也差不多了。有趣的是，我不认为——嗯，这在某种程度上是一样的。就像，你知道，史蒂夫和史蒂夫，对吧，著名的在车库里创造了 Apple One。而且，你知道，也为 Apple II 做了工作。规模非常小。而且你今天绝对不会那样做去与 Mac 或 Windows 电脑竞争。绝对没戏。但同时对他们来说，他们正在创造最终将与小型机和大机竞争的东西，而他们当时没有办法直接与那些竞争
these days is really low i mean if you look at small startups like Tilt 5, which just does an amazing setup for augmented reality for board games, which is very cool. And so it's little Pico projectors in glasses uh jerry ellsworth's work absolutely brilliant hardware and it's basically you know one woman a small company a small team who's who's who's doing uh this this relatively inexpensive custom hardware i guess you have a i guess you have a fair point um yeah and so you know and you see like one-off little consumer products all over the place will somebody build an entry-level laptop or os or something that eventually displaces mac and windows i don't know maybe
是的，令人惊叹的是，如今做像小型入门级硬件这样的门槛真的很低。我的意思是，如果你看看像 Tilt 5 这样的小型初创公司，它为棋盘游戏做了令人惊叹的增强现实设置，这非常酷。所以它是眼镜中的微型 Pico 投影仪——杰里·埃尔斯沃思（Jerry Ellsworth）的作品，绝对是 brilhant 的硬件，它基本上是……你知道的，一个女人，一个小型公司，一个小型团队，正在制作这种相对便宜的定制硬件。我想你有一个——我想你有一个合理的观点——是的，所以你知道，你到处都能看到这种一次性的消费级产品。会有人构建最终取代 Mac 和 Windows 的入门级笔记本电脑或操作系统吗？我不知道，也许吧
you know i think it's it's doable um really it's just you're not going to start with a head-on attack. You're going to start building something that Apple and Microsoft view as a non-threat toy in the same way that Deck viewed the Apple II as a toy. Not anything that would be at all competitive
你知道，我认为这是可行的，真的，这只是意味着你不会以正面攻击开始。你会开始构建一些被 Apple 和 Microsoft 视为无威胁玩具的东西，就像 DEC 将 Apple II 视为玩具一样。没有任何东西可以与它们竞争
with them ever. Have you tried this? Because I had never heard of Tilt 5 5 and when you mentioned ar board games i have always thought that uh i've only ever done one dnd campaign dungeons and dragons for the one percent of our audience that doesn't know what that refers to and uh it was cool but it was done virtually during the pandemic with my siblings and siblings partners and it was uh very cool but it was done through like a 2d online you know like you're going to the board and whatnot and it's i think you get a lot more out of having like a real board or if you go to
甚至一点点。你尝试过这个吗？因为我以前从未听说过 Tilt 5，当你提到 AR 棋盘游戏时，我一直认为——我只参加过一次 DND 战役（龙与地下城，针对我们听众中百分之一不知道那是什么意思的人），而且它很酷，但在大流行期间通过虚拟方式与我的兄弟姐妹以及兄弟姐妹的伴侣一起完成的，非常酷，但它是通过类似 2D 在线的方式进行的（你知道的，就像你去棋盘上之类的那样），我认为拥有一个真正的棋盘，或者如果你去游戏商店，你会有一个那种类似于——你知道的——战场或其它什么，你会从中获得更多。你曾经在游戏商店玩过 DND 吗？没有，但我去过游戏商店。相信我，拥有在线功能来跟踪所有状态实际上非常方便。好吧，我的观点是，无论你是否是与一个精于移动物品、制造空间意识事物的地牢主（Dungeon Master）亲自进行，还是在 2D 东西上进行，真正首要的、世界级的体验是你想要的这种 AR 东西，地牢主在战役开始前就已经提前设置好了不同的角落，哦，雾气飘了过来。当然，地牢主可以叙述这一点，但只要一挥手，雾气实际上就会出现在这上面。你可以虚拟地完成它。每个人都有一副眼镜。
a game store and you have one of those sort of like you know uh not battlefields or whatever have you have you have you ever played dnd at a at a game store no but i have been to uh game stores trust me having the online thing to like keep track of all the state is actually very convenient okay well my point my point being though is regardless of if you're doing it in person with a dungeon master that is expert at you know moving things around making spatially aware stuff or you're doing it on this 2D thing, the real, like, first, like, you know, world-class experience that you want is this kind of AR thing where the dungeon master has, you know, ahead of the campaign gone forward, set this up of the different corners that you, oh, the mist comes over. Sure, the Dungeon Master can narrate that, but with the swoosh of a hand, the mist actually appears on this. And you could do it virtually. Everyone has a set of glasses.
他们只是盯着任何桌子。我想用我的想象力。这就像读书一样。电影很好，但有时人们想读一读书。好吧。布莱斯没有被邀请参加我未来将使用这种 Tilt 5 技术进行的龙与地下城战役。但我访问了这个网站。就在你提到那个的时候，我想，等等，难道已经有一家公司拥有这样做的硬件了吗？
They're just staring at whatever table. I want to use my imagination. It's like reading a book. Movies are nice, but sometimes one wants to read a book. All right. Bryce is not invited to the future Dungeons & Dragons campaign that I will have using this Tilt 5 technology. But I went to this site. And as soon as you said that, I was like, wait, is there a company that already has the hardware to do this?
果不其然，他们有一个关于它的微型演示。它没有展示 DND 战役，但正是这种每个人都有一个小控制器并在玩这些有趣小游戏的场景。无论如何，这是一个冗长的表述，说明这是我脑海深处的一件事，未来的这项技术会很棒。你用过这个吗？你知道它是否真的达到了你可以做这种事情的程度吗？哦，是的，所以 Tilt 5 的东西实际上是杰里的第二代。请务必收听我们明年的节目，届时我们将完成与肖恩·帕伦特关于 Tilt 5、增强现实等内容的第三部分，也是三部分对话的最后一部分。并且请务必在你的播客应用程序中或通过 adsptopodcast.com 查看你的节目说明，以获取我们在今天的节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及指向 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下评论、想法和问题。感谢收听。
And sure enough, they've got like a little demo of it. It doesn't show a D&D campaign, but exactly this kind of thing where everyone's got a little controller and they're playing these little fun games. Anyways, this is a long-winded of like this is something that's been in the back of my head of like this future technology would be awesome have you used this and do you know if like it's actually at the state where you can do this kind of stuff oh yeah so so this is the tilt 5 stuff is actually jerry's you know second generation be sure to tune in next year when we finish part three of our three-part conversation with sean parent about tilt 5 5, augmented reality, and more. And be sure to check your show notes either in your podcast app or at adsptopodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, and questions. Thanks for listening.
我们希望你喜欢本期节目并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息 sprinkles 的混乱。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望你喜欢本期节目，并祝你有美好的一天。质量不高，数量凑。这就是我们播客的标语。其实不是这个。我们的标语是“混乱中带有一点信息”。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。